good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Thursday in March of
2023 that really feels like a Thursday
in March of 2020 because we are
podcasting from home today Audio Only I
haven't sat at this desk to podcast
since dark dark times hey Jax how you
doing that's so funny because for me it
doesn't feel that way because I'm still
in my studio so I'm like at work but I'm
in my pajamas so I'm working from PJs
because I'm sick I know I'm I'm sick
it's sorry you go my illness has just
been like a little bit of a journey like
I woke up this morning I'll explain what
I have so I've had a cold you guys have
heard over the last like two weeks
sneezing whatever yesterday was really
bad sinus pressure in my nose and my
head
before I went to sleep last night like I
had the humidifier going cold compress
on my nose and then I was sleeping I
slept really well and then I woke up
before my hatch alarm even started and I
woke up coughing like my throat was on
fire and like the coughs like I felt
like I couldn't catch my breath what I
think now what happened is that it was
all the mucus like went down into my
throat while I was asleep because I was
on my back and on my side so
um you know gravity did its thing and
the first few minutes that I was waiting
the first 10 minutes like I was like oh
I can't do the toes today at all then I
sat up and I had a tea and then like 30
minutes later I was like okay I'm sick
but I could I could talk for an hour I
just can't spend an hour doing my makeup
which is why we're Audio Only okay so
that's called post nasal drip I learned
because like when I get like a little
bit sick in the mornings I'm on death's
door I have to go to the hospital and
what I've learned is that that's called
post nasal drip like that's why you feel
like in the morning when you're
sick but you're not as sick as you feel
just because the mornings are so bad
yeah yeah no that's what it was but also
like with pregnancy your um nose Canal
is just like inflamed already so like
sinus Tings are are real
um but I had never felt my throat feel
like that in my life so maybe I've just
not had like a bad sinus experience but
I was like holy and I was reading
up on like sinusitis last night when I
thought that might be what I had and
then all of a sudden I was having these
symptoms that last night I could say I
didn't have like even tooth hurt tooth
hurt well I think I speak on behalf of
myself and all the toasters when I say
thank you for still showing up for work
today if you're a regular podcast
listener your life remains unaffected if
you're a YouTuber check out today's
podcast this audio is also available on
YouTube if you're just like a YouTube
app girly but hopefully Jax will be
better by tomorrow
um if not it's Friday so at least we
have the weekend and then you'll
definitely be back by Monday yeah so I'm
gonna take the day today after this like
just be in bed tea soup water rest Bryce
who just knows when his mom
um needs him desperately like it's crazy
how he's he's Florence Bryce and Gail
he's he's also just like extremely
intuitive no he really really is like
it's crazy the things that he he picks
up on but I'm hoping that tomorrow I'll
be better because honestly I'm too
booked and busy for this right now like
and and I'm not even particularly booked
this weekend I just like
have a busy
life like I don't drive now like I'm
obviously not driving today I'm not
going anywhere but like I have things to
do Harry needs to play telum
the life of a mogul
and a mother
the life of a mogul mother Mogul mother
it's really like I'm super busy and
Harry can't have me down and out he's
like Mom let's go no he was actually he
was texting me this morning being like
you know like I understand like she's
sick but like like low-key it's kind of
annoying we have plans and I just feel
like maybe she's faking because she's
just like not in the mood to hang out
with me and I said how are you
absolutely not like Jackie mom would
never she would literally never do that
she's in she's in agony knowing that she
might not be able to give you 110 today
and I think I definitely like talked him
down off the ledge but he was feeling
like kind of you know kind of shuttered
I mean we all are when I can't give 110
to my sweet Deary the mother is the
heartbeat of the household that's
beautiful where'd you read that turdy
Lou I just made it up and I'm literally
ready to write my next Novella I'm
obsessed put that on a little uh Baby
Onesie pillows called like a tea pillow
I think it's called yeah like those ones
that are stitched like a yeah yeah yeah
or we could put it on a baby onesie and
sell it at shop morning oh no
toastmarch.com oh my God I love that the
mother is the heartbeat of the household
okay like I definitely feel like I made
it up and now like that you're saying
it's so profound I must have heard it
somewhere okay let me Google it quickly
even though then I'm sure I'll find it
somewhere but let me see if it's um but
I want everyone to know before Jackie
maybe finds someone who said it like I
genuinely just thought of it and and I
really did make it up like I did and
there's such a thing my new favorite
term is parallel thinking yeah two
people can have the same thought and the
same idea and neither one of them is
copying the other because like we are
all humans with a brain because the idea
of what I just said like isn't
necessarily an original thought you know
moms do run the household
the mother is a heartbeat in the home
it's not like so obvious like there is
an Amazon book
called mother is the heartbeat in the
home and I still feel I found her there
seems to be no heartthrob
okay well mine was better keep it
shorter keep it short
um
yeah no maybe coming to toastmarch.com
to you know maybe yeah TBD
so
I'm so glad you're here because I wanted
to tell you I know you already saw
because I posted on my Instagram Ben has
been in Alabama this week doing Spritz
stuff and today it actually worked out
nicely he's going to the Bahamas for a
bachelor party he was already South he
was just gonna go straight from Alabama
to the Bahamas and he's at the airport
and he's texted me I don't have my
passport
I'm obsessed let me tell you why you
know obviously my heart aches for my
husband who's now in a pickle you know
it's one of his best friends I don't
know how he's gonna get there there's
really I'm useless there's nothing I can
do like what I'm gonna fly to the
Bahamas and meet him like no there's
nothing I can do it's not like he's in
New York you know if he was at Newark he
would just have to come back to the
house yeah
no he is out of luck
and I can't help but wonder you know how
a this wouldn't have happened if we were
traveling together
B I feel so Vindicated for every time
we've traveled abroad and he's made me
feel crazy for like my checklist and
getting early to the airport and packing
24 hours before not the day of Ben is
always just flying by the seat of his
pants always doing things last minute
and kind of irresponsibly but I'm always
there to catch him like there's never
any repercussions for his kind of crazy
lifestyle because I'm always there to
pick up the pieces and today I wasn't
and I just can't help I know you guys
can't see me recording but I'm recording
this with a smile like I am so I I like
obviously like I my heart hurts for him
like that sucks but like I just feel
like every time he's ever like called me
crazy or like made fun of me for I'm so
with the airport I'm so meticulous I'm
so timely I'm probably over overly
cautious and I get mocked for it and
look at the consequences when you are
not overly cautious this is what happens
Ben so maybe the next time you think
about making fun of your wife you just
lick her ass for doing
everything for you you literally
literally I too have a smile on my face
because you know I've been hearing like
all of these Ben stories and I really
have wanted you to punish him like I
want him to pay for his crimes and to
feel the consequences of his actions and
today we didn't have to lift a finger
and he self-sabotaged no it wasn't
self-sabotage Jackie like you've been
wanting me to punish him like not invite
him to this like to make it like the
punishment would have been like taking
the passport out of his bag but the
universe like rewarded me for being the
bigger person which I never am and like
like this was God
yeah
I'm I have to get I have to pray but
like what is he gonna do I don't know I
told him I'm like it's Thursday so why
don't you just fly home
come to your passport spend the night
here and leave in the morning and you'll
be there first thing Friday morning for
a bachelor party I don't think it's a
big deal but Ben had this big plan he
drove to the Pensacola Airport because
it was like the perfect flight to get to
the Bahamas he was flying through Miami
so now there's no random flights from
Pensacola to New York he's like really
he's oh my God
yeah I have to look at a map of where
Pensacola is because there are some big
airports like in the Panhandle no and
like he I think he's maybe like an hour
flight from Atlanta so you just take a
flight to Atlanta and then Atlanta you
can get anywhere but the thing is so
true the thing is
this is not my story problem it's not my
monkey like I'm not gonna be over here
you know making travel plans especially
for somebody who's so relentlessly
mocked me for years I'm just I'm not
gonna be that girl not today I'm busy
you know I'm running an Empire my sister
is sick like I have other things to do
yeah Pensacola oh wow I see where he is
now I do have I do have like a a plan I
could do that does benefit me
I think I know
and if it's me yeah I told Ben still
take that flight from Pensacola to Miami
but don't get on the second leg to the
Bahamas spend the night at the Shapiro's
or the wine rebs I will come down spend
the weekend in Florida with my family
and I'll bring your passport
but I haven't told him that I
desperately I desperately want you to do
that because I would love to see you but
like I don't know like my
is just as sweet as my taste for seeing
you that's how it's like riled up I've
been over his actions I know I don't
want to help like I I think it's so
important that people learn from their
mistakes honestly and like stuff like
this happens to Ben all the time like we
showed up to the airport in Florida
to go home from like spending a week at
your house and he left his wallet at
your house like things like this always
happen and I don't feel like he will
really learn if I'm like and you know
what on during that time I got on the
flight like I had Theo I was like you
know what this is a you problem now and
it was It was obviously it wasn't as
dire as this but like in situations like
this I really don't feel like fixing it
for him because it his problems will
only get worse really yeah and you're
supposed to be here next week so would
you just stay
yeah I guess that's not so bad that's
really not so bad I'm supposed to fly to
you on Thursday oh no I have to be in
New York on Thursday for a work thing oh
so no you're not coming for a weekend to
bail him out no I'm not no and then I
feel like spend money on flights like
then I'm like you know being Bamboozled
and so I do think like fresh air and
like a green environment is would be
best for Theo right now while he's
recovering well in his recovery you know
he kind of means like dry out down here
actually
um drying out is exactly what he needs
to not do that's why I've been giving
him drops four times a day because if
his eyes get dry his abrasion gets worse
oh okay but still he should come down
here for some r r 100 percent
uh okay you're not coming I can't
believe I'm saying that like don't come
but this is so important that we that
it's a teachable moment Jackie we're on
the same page don't worry I'm not
offended a teachable moment is what this
must become
and there is a path where he can it's
still it's only Thursday he could go
home he could see his wife he could
check on his one-eyed son thank you and
then go on a bachelor party on Friday
like since when do you need to go for
like a five-day weekend on a bachelor
party no no I know I know
so that's just like you know a win for
the Naggy wives column today so we
can all celebrate today's Justice news
yeah today in judicial news the Naggy
wives have won tourney what's the
saying the wheels of Justice turn slowly
so true hold on the wheels I always
forget the second the wheels of Justice
grind slowly yet they grind exceedingly
well
eatingly
exceedingly and that uh it refers to the
notion of slow but certain divine
retribution that's what this is it is
divine retribution move over Divine
diversion divine retribution is what I
seek
and today we have it and we need to
celebrate no not even to celebrate like
take a moment we're always saying how
important it is to acknowledge a space
that we're in like we feel like I know
Ben is like understanding how vital my
my presence is in his life right now and
I'm feeling just
overwhelmed
with like Vindication
but also like
like he feels dumb like he feels dumb I
know he does he has to and that feels
good yeah that does feel good
wow some great news this morning
everyone I'm feeling sick but I'm I'm
feeling motivated yeah it shows good
work that we do show's over like we've
accomplished what we set up to
accomplish it's so true no Show's not
over because we have to talk about the
Vanderpump Rules episode from last night
we have to talk about Raquel lettuce
sitting outside this Fort Lawrence
shopping center
um being approached by TMZ so that's
what we have to do today yeah and I
personally feel like I can get right
into it you know my update is that
I'm sick and ew you yeah and
that's all for me and everybody is
experiencing divine retribution so
you know so it's a win for both hosts
honestly it is it is so without further
adieu here are the fast five stories
that you need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
State Farm the State Farm personal price
plan helps you create a plan that gives
you options so you get an affordable
price and it comes with a lot of
benefits like the coverage you want a
policy that helps cover what's important
to you and an affordable price just for
you because after all life is better
when you can personalize your
experiences I love that that's a
quarterstone of State Farm's brand
because it's definitely a Cornerstone of
our brand I think we're always talking
here about how important personalization
is and how personal certain things can
be you know like comedy like food like
poetry what else are we saying is so
personal
ooh comedy food poetry reading reading
Justice
this is personal yet it grinds
exceedingly well
personalization means you have the power
to choose what you want to include and
what you want to leave out it just feels
better that way and why shouldn't
insurance work like that too I mean name
two people who are more similar than
Jackson I and even Jax and I require
completely different insurance plans I
mean Jackie is a Tesla Jackie's a
homeowner I have really nothing in my
life but Jackie has a lot
that's what the State Farm personal
price plan is all about you can choose
to include options like bundling your
home and auto policies and that means
you'll get the coverage you want at an
affordable price just for you in the end
you'll have a policy that gives you what
you want doesn't that feel better
so like a good neighbor State Farm is
there excuse me like a good neighbor
stay Farms
there we're doing really good before you
started laughing oh really yeah like you
sounded really good I was about to say
like turdy Loom they might tap you call
or go to statefarm.com today to create
your State Farm personal price plan
prices vary by state options selected by
customer availability and eligibility
may vary today's episode is also is also
brought to you by Athena Club okay I'm
excited about being a club because you
know it's that time of year where we're
all getting away with not shaving so
frequently but it's time to get friendly
with your razor again and I just got a
brand new razor from Athena Club that's
like hanging in my shower the one that I
have is called Smooth Operator
um and there's no better time to get to
shaving and there's no better razor out
there than the Athena Club razor shaving
used to be something we all dreaded but
Athena club's products seriously make it
more fun and easy to shave not only is
it the prettiest razor I've ever seen
but it's also more gentle on my skin it
leaves it moisturized super smooth and
bump free I am prone to bumps I have
like lots of things going on on my legs
in different parts of my legs and I
can't just be using some crap razor you
know I need a premium experienced
premium products and that's what you
need a shaving cream Athena Club has the
best shaving cream I feel like we've all
forgotten about shaving cream once we
learned that like we could dry shave in
the sink and like you know just raw dog
it but you guys shaving your legs with
shaving cream is the way God intended
for you to shave it makes such a
difference in the after result Athena
clubs razors have thousands of five star
reviews from customers and it's designed
with built-in skin guard to help prevent
razor burn while it's also gentle on
your curves the razor blade is
surrounded by a water activated Serum
with shea butter and hyaluronic acid
which is the Holy Grail for skin care
the best part is that their razor kit is
only nine dollars and it comes with two
blade heads a magnetic hook for the
shower which is my favorite part and
your choice of handle color of course I
got pink the handle color options are so
cute but even uh black and white razors
for all the minimalists out there they
have at Athena Club so you never have to
think about the blade refills because
you choose now how often you want your
replacement blades they'll be shipped to
you for free and you'll never be stuck
with an overused blade longer than it
should be used for head to
athenaclub.com and use code toast for 25
off your first order again that's
athenaclub.com use code toast for 25 off
Athena Club is also launching in Target
stores nationwide this month so make
sure you check out their shaving aisle
to buy their products in store in real
life
thank you Claudia two wonderful sponsors
you're welcome
our first story we're actually going to
shake things up today because it makes
sense for The Narrative of this show and
because like we're podcasting from home
we can kind of like do whatever the
we want yeah what do you think turdy Lou
I agree so here's how it's gonna go
first story is BPR news because Raquel
spoke to TMZ at length then we're gonna
go into VPR recap Vanderpump Rules recap
because we're going to be talking about
these characters and like we're going to
want to talk about the show so we're
going to talk about the show you know
it's just for for streamlining the TV
recap starts right now for continuity's
sake because typically if there was like
a Vanderpump story I'd make it Fifth to
go into the TV recap but Raquel's
interview to TMZ is the number one story
of the day and Jax is the number one guy
in this group 100
so Raquel was caught outside Raquel was
you forgot to do air quotes caught well
I want to talk about that yeah but let's
just go with the flow for now she was
caught outside her local nail salon
getting her nails done for the reunion I
presume and TMZ cameraman was there
asking Raquel all of the questions and
she was feeling chatty as it's the
first time she's spoken since she put
out a statement and a couple uh social
media posts and she's really talking at
length and there were a few things that
she wouldn't answer because you know
it's going to come up in the reunion
also not her place to answer like what
did Ariana say to her like you better
not tell us You Wench yeah she
didn't
um she's sitting there if you didn't see
the video she is wearing no makeup her
hood is up she's wearing air pods and
big glasses you can't see her hair like
it's a very not glamorous moment for her
no but I think even Raquel knows like if
she had set this up and showed up
completely Glam people would
automatically know that it was a setup
and now like knowing that she looks kind
of haggard people are definitely like
well maybe it wasn't a setup it's really
making me question to set up this
because
no I know it's effective because I feel
like there's a way to show up not in
Glam but like
still looking pretty looking like a
million millions of people are gonna see
this video like I want to put my best my
a foot forward this really like to me
she really looks like she got caught but
maybe that's because she really wants us
to believe she got caught and that she
didn't call TMZ herself I mean when they
call when they said hey Raquel and she
looked up and saw a camera she didn't
appear to be incredibly shocked and by
the way if it was totally caught off
guard she could have walked away she
could have gone inside to the nail salon
like she just continued to sit there
like I definitely believe that it was a
a coordinated Affair yeah I do too
because like TMZ doesn't just like lurk
around this shopping center like when
they're at the airport you know they
wait at LAX to meet some Talent that's
where Tom Schwartz was caught on TMZ at
the airport I think he was but he was
going to Winter house
so it's also confusing yeah but he was
at the airport
not LAX
no no but he was at the airport like
airports are airports are total like
free-for-alls when it comes to Paparazzi
also like there have been Paparazzi
stationed outside of Raquel's apartment
building and Ariana's house so if it had
been there like maybe I don't know turnt
nail salon has so shook me and you know
if I am the owner of that nail salon I
would kiss Raquel on the mouth for
sitting right in front of our logo Bliss
Nails Bliss Nails like no Bloom Nails
blue nails oh like what marketing that
was maybe Raquel owns a nail salon like
that's how intentional it seemed yeah
well they could have followed her from
her house but regardless the story is
what she said she talks about how she is
going to the reunion today and she
posted on her story she will be in
person at the reunion today she says
that she has to take accountability for
everything she was asked whether or not
her and Tom are together right now and
she said that
neither yes nor no but they're just like
seeing what happens you know they have a
few like things they obviously need to
get through right who knows what will
happen at the reunion they're not like
saying to each other we're together
forever we're riding through this but
they're also not being like Oh we
up like see you never right I think it
was a pretty good answer just being like
we can't figure that out until we like
get ourselves out of the shitstorm we
created right which is a good way of
handling things in life honestly
yeah no I I think that's what they
should be doing but I do I weirdly hope
that they stay together they have to I
mean that's the only way to make this
whole thing worth it yeah yeah
um so her voice like you know she's very
um
I mean I don't know what she's like now
but as far as we've known like she's
been like kind of timid and even in this
most recent episode where she's standing
up for herself like her voice is like
shaky and she like cracks and I thought
she did a pretty decent job of like
handling herself and and keeping her
composure although her voice did crack
and it sounded like she was about to cry
when she did say that like she's you
know she has to take accountability for
her actions at the reunion tomorrow like
in the very beginning of the video
yeah her voice she's always had like you
know timidness in her voice but to me
she kind of sounded like
she
is like I don't not on drugs not like um
not like high but yeah like on drugs
over-the-counter drugs like I don't know
Xanax ssris like something because she
was just like extremely like muted
almost like David mellow yeah we'll see
like girl your whole world blew up like
you're just sitting here talking to TMZ
like it's a regular Tuesday no that's
actually like a decent point it's very
possible like with her therapist that
she was talking about like she got a
prescription for something because I can
imagine how like not only is your
personal life like Beyond imploding but
it's happening on a global scale like
that will drive anyone to uh a Xanax
Insanity yeah yeah so that's like kind
of what she sounded like to me I just
like I'm really struggling I wonder if
anyone else can relate to this because
so clearly are Raquel and Tom in the
wrong in the Scandal thing but we're
watching you know TV
of something entirely different and what
I'm watching on TV like I'm so team
rockelle like it's so crazy to me and I
don't know how to balance those parallel
thoughts no that's actually not the
right use sorry no there are two
thoughts that are on separate tracks yes
they're actually like perpendicular
thoughts because they're so different
they're about to intersect but they have
right now they're cruising and they're
going to intersect and so you'll have to
figure out how to deal with them so
they're not parallel because parallel
lines never intersect right I agree
and we can get into the show but what
I'm doing is I'm just evaluating the
show for the show's sake and if I see
anything between Sandoval and Marquel
like that's what I'm picking up on but
between Raquel and like the girls
it is what it is and in this situation
it's so crazy because literally everyone
is wrong like everyone is right about
one thing and wrong about another thing
like Raquel is right that those girls
like brought her there just to like be
mean girls and maybe they don't you know
the their mean girl ways aren't like how
they were 10 years ago when they were
outright bullying Sheena but like to all
giggle in one room and just sleep in one
room together and then like you know say
be nice to her when she walks in and
talk when she leaves and then like
lala had said like oh no we thought the
Galaxy lights were sick like no you
didn't you thought she was gonna murder
you I was so glad that they had the
flashback so like in that situation like
I think Raquel versus The Mean Girls
like Raquel is right but then she runs
outside and goes to schwart's like your
wife is this and that like shut up stay
out of their divorce and everything
between Schwartz and Katie Raquel is
wrong yeah then like Sheena weirdly I
think that Sheena Is Right about the
hotel thing of course sheena's right
about the hotel thing it's weird to me
like I understand wanting to with
like being Katie and one to with
Sheena because she's been with
you and like oh Sheena wants something
I'm not giving to her but if it requires
going to Mexico
to a wedding that you're not going to to
sit in your hotel room to watch from
your balcony like why would you want to
do that like just to with Sheena
like that's losery to me so in that
situation sheena's right Katie's wrong
but Katie's right in the Schwartz
situation and she knows wrong in every
other situation when she runs outside
it's like your wife like shut up you as
well she never tell need to stay out of
the Bubba marriage right like up until
this point Katie's biggest crime was
just like really who she was associated
with but like when it came to the Rock
hell thing like she was totally
justified in her anger but this Sheena
thing is so bizarre because like and I
by the way I agree with you I totally
get wanting to stick it to Sheena like
Sheena but it's making Katie look
so bad because like one why the do
you want to be at the hotel and she's
like it's not like we're gonna stand on
the balcony and then it turns out that's
exactly what she does and the fact that
she's bringing Christina Kelly who like
clearly Sheena is still not sure is
literally famous for making fun of
sheena's first wedding yeah you were
going she hasn't been on the show in
years you're bringing her back to go to
sheena's second wedding like I
understand why Sheena would be like get
that girl girl imagine someone you knew
was making fun of your wedding and then
someone who's like in your circle not
your friend but like you know on and off
was bringing that person to be around
your second wedding no I know that's
literally all Christina Kelly is known
for so the fact that it's Christina
Kelly who she's bringing is like another
layer and it really just makes Katie
look so bad and like everyone was
pleading with her like trying to pay her
and she wouldn't let it go like she was
wrong she she made herself look really
bad and I and I understand the intention
I really do
um but this is not the way to win if
anything it makes everyone more
sympathetic to Sheena and everyone was
taking her side and she's just like
isolating herself with Lala and
Christina Kelly and that's like not a
cool crew right now no it's not the
other Cruise not cool either though yeah
so that's it's everyone and also from
what we saw Sheena did not ask Katie
like I don't know if she ever asked her
off camera or it just wasn't film but
like we only got like Sheena like
demanding that Katie give up the room
not like listen Katie I know you're not
coming to my wedding but I also know
like you're kind of stuck with the trip
like I one of my bridesmaids actually
doesn't have a room I would love to buy
it off of you that way you could spend
the money going somewhere else and my
bridesmaid gets to stay at the hotel
yeah no she went about it in the wrong
way for sure because when you need
something from someone and especially
that person doesn't like you like you
have to be yeah yeah
and ask nice now watching the episode
knowing what we know it was really
interesting to see Tom Sandoval like so
sticking up for Raquel even though I
don't think that would have alerted me
of anything because Tom Sandoval is like
always getting involved that that
doesn't you know require his attention
and that was just like another thing
that Tom was doing but for the first
time in his goddamn life he was like
partially on the right side of History
yeah no and also Tom Sandoval was doing
it because he likes going toe-to-toe
with Lala and he likes sewing toe-to-toe
with Katie Katie he just liked arguing
with them and I think it this stage in
all everyone's relationship he sees
Raquel like a little sister and like
someone didn't like they were being
cruel to her she was also like she's
dumb and drunk and she sounds like a
and Lala is just coming in like a
wolf which like it's just it's
overpowering and Raquel didn't need
people to stand up for her like the way
that Ariana stood up with her for her
was like so nice and I think her
intentions were really pure because
everybody there is her friend yeah now
in hindsight it's like wow and you
turned on you betrayed this girl you're
disgusting yeah it was just it was a
very interesting episode to watch and
then there's like this side story of
James Kennedy feeling like he's being
pushed out of the group and it's so
funny
um and it's kind of odd that Sheena like
invited his girlfriend to the wedding
festivities but not the wedding like
she's coming to the welcome party in the
after party and the cocktail party but
not the actual wedding and I don't
understand that because like I
understand Brides who are like no ring
no bring I understand that there's like
I totally get that when it's a
destination wedding to invite like
certain people to selected events like
that's bizarre bizarre also they do live
together though prematurely and like
that is usually the policy like because
not like if you said no ring no brain
Tom and Ariana like yeah so like living
together typically gets you an invite
plus James is a groomsman and a
groomsman typically gets a plus one also
I thought it was a little tacky that she
didn't invite Ali honestly and because
it's destination and you know Ali's
upstairs in the hotel room it's like if
she wasn't invited and she wasn't going
to Mexico fine but like knowing she's
going to Mexico you toss an invite
because Oh Katie Maloney's not going
there's a chair right
was Katie Maloney before they you know
stopped being friends but she had
bridesmaid or just like a guest
I think just a guest okay Sheena
bridesmaid in her wedding yes wow times
have changed times have changed and then
did you watch Jax and Brittany on watch
it happens live I did oh my God I mean
could anyone get a word in the whole
time I felt like everyone there was like
on Adderall like I think Jackson Britney
were so excited they had so much to say
so much to update and you know Andy like
his style of interviewing is rushing
through like oh you have an answer I'm
not even listening to it because I'm on
to the next question I have to play this
dumb game that nobody cares about right
so it was like Not only was that classic
Andy like rushed shtick there it was
Brittany and Jax who both have so much
to say it's been so long so much has
happened even if the Scandal didn't
happen we still have to like you know
hear so much from them in terms of like
updates in their lives that it was
honestly like I couldn't keep up they
kept talking over each other Andy kept
cutting them off like it was literally
the episode like the theme of the
episode was Adderall because it just
felt like everyone was just like
non-stop talking
yeah it was chaotic I'm not saying that
they were on Adderall by the way I'm
just saying like that was the vibe when
the episode started I just felt like
they were so excited to be like back at
watchdrop inside there's so much
catching up to do they have a baby like
Jax was right about everything like
they're just hyped up they have this new
podcast they're promoting by the end of
the episode I felt like
I don't know if they felt this way but I
felt this way for them where like they
were like oh we didn't miss this being
spoken down to by Andy like he's so
condescending towards him he's always
been so rude towards Jax but like he was
just rude to the both of them just in
his way you know just snide remarks
about like everything that they said
that was just dumb and by the end I was
like I bet you they're so glad to get
out of here of course you want to be on
TV of course it's a good career but like
I don't think they miss the way that
Andy made them feel all those years I
completely agree
um and I thought it was really
interesting when they shared that they
were asked to film at sheena's wedding
and they declined and stayed at another
hotel and it really made me feel like
even you know more confident in their
relationship like they're not clamoring
to get back on TV like they really are
just happy and they went to enjoy the
weekend and not like make it about them
and I was I was shocked to hear that
yeah Zach and I were watching it
together and I was also just really
remarking about how normal they are as a
couple like when they were talking about
something that Jax does that like
bothers Brittany didn't know what she
was gonna say and then she goes
sometimes you have a hairy butt yeah
yeah we were just like cracking up like
that's just so personal they're just
like such regular people yeah and they
really defied all the odds I don't know
how someone like Jax goes from being
like a pathological serial cheater liar
to being like father of the year husband
of the year it's a shocking
transformation but I really feel like
like he is walking in this path and like
they're really happy with their lives no
it was really nice to see I completely
agree and I feel like Andy just wouldn't
like give them that you know he was like
really just trying to keep Jax in the
box that he knows and it was like why
don't we like allow space for people
like it really does seem like Jax has
evolved and he was even you know
self-aware enough to say like by the way
I'm going to talk about this skin of all
things but like I know how it sounds
like I've been there I've cheated I've
made mistakes so you can ask me
questions but just don't know I'm not
dumb enough to think that like I'm
better than this like I've been there
right right so I just don't know like
why it couldn't have been acknowledged
like how much has changed and they
really are the last couple standing and
they have this beautiful family and
they're not thirsty like they're really
not yeah they're really not so I I they
are launching a podcast it drops on
Tuesday so that was like perfect time
for them to come and Watch What Happens
Live and promote it I truly wish them
all the best I think they're really
really nice couple they seem genuinely
happy and they have defied all of the
odds so true I was sad to hear about
them and stassi because like it's clear
that Brittany loves stassian like so
does Jacks and I know that the wedding
was like a problem because they
basically like the last minute said they
weren't going and likes tell us he like
paid for everyone and it was like you
know really small wedding and it was
whatever
um and you could tell that they were
like both really sad that stassi was mad
at them
it's sad I hope that they can forgive
that's something that's for that's
annoying like upsetting but forgivable
agreed and um I also just found it
interesting to hear who Britney is like
close with she's really close machine
and she's really close with Chris and
Dodie yeah I just feel like everyone
loved Brittany and then I felt like I
think he's friends with all the girls
still
yeah yeah not Raquel she doesn't know
her yeah yeah no I just I I found it
like interesting yeah they're very much
like still in the mix yeah even though
it seems like online like they're not
no it seems like with the kids like the
lollipops yeah
crew yeah Cruz is like all their girl's
boyfriend
yeah he's so just like all their kids
are so cute oh my God totally
Cruz is so cute did you see him sleeping
on Santa Claus over Christmas no they
took him to see Santa but he was napping
and he literally is sleeping on Santa in
the pictures that's so cute oh also you
know I was glad Andy asked because like
I actually was really
um interested and struck by the
conversation the storyline that Jax had
about his mom after his um Dad had
passed away and I was surprised and
delighted to hear that he had like made
an initial like he reached out and they
connected and like hopefully they're on
the road to some sort of
yeah
that was nice to hear there was one
other thing that they talked about oh I
mean the headline from their episode is
that Jack said Tom Sandoval cheated on
Ariana one week into their relationship
with Miami girl he cheated on her
throughout the years he knows these
things to be true yeah I mean not
shocking I don't think you just like
have an affair like but when he said it
doesn't matter if he cheated once or
cheated 10 times and everyone was like
no yeah no it matters Yeah a
hundred percent either either you made a
mistake or you're a serious
yeah it totally makes a difference like
one time don't try it with me but like
one time could be like I do see how
people can get past that forgivable
right ten times you have no respect for
me you're just get out of my house get
out yeah no not the same not the same at
all yeah okay so that's VPR for this
week Vanderpump Rules they're filming
the reunion today right right now
they're getting ready if anybody they're
not listening I don't really think many
of them are toasters but what I just
would like for them to do is take a
breath everybody is so hyped up and I'm
worried they're gonna ruin it by all
descending and and just like making
themselves distracting from what we need
to talk about which is so right
Tom Raquel and Ariana like everybody
else who has their opinions and is like
just like sharks circling
calm down please you'll have your moment
but like please do not distract from the
task at hand yeah everybody needs to
make themselves small yeah no but
instead they're all just gonna like jump
on this yeah and and their behavior is
going to be bad too so like I just I
don't want it to get lost what we need
to talk about yeah also I don't know how
because this is like kind of
unprecedented how do you
like
schedule a reunion like this because
usually like you go in Parts in the
beginning of the season is reunion part
one you have to open with the scandival
you have to open this no no if they if
they don't open with this I will be
picketing outside of 30 Rock like there
is this is unprecedented like I
understand you want to tease the big
stuff for the end there's no talking
about anything before it's scannable
there isn't so agreed I hope they're not
dumb enough to think we're gonna go for
that agreed
and the problem is how do you talk about
anything else how are we going to talk
about you know
Sheena and Brock's wedding in the hotel
room drama right it's so irrelevant now
it's so small yeah
or like James and Ally who cares who
cares Havasu
Havasu yeah are you ready for our next
story which is super reality TV news yes
but all I want to say is last night's
episode was missing Charlie like she's
now what I look forward to
yeah the thing about Charlie though and
I was remembering when I watched Watch
What Happens Live is like she takes aim
at something like she goes all the way
and like she really you know is like a
Canon but sometimes she just like aims
her yeah it's still in the wrong
direction like when she went after
Jack's at the reunion it's like how do
you guys even know each other it was so
random and it would like for me that's
why I was like kind of put off by her
because it was clearly just like a ploy
for air time yeah um it wasn't because
she felt you know so passionately but
this time she got it right yeah she was
just a little misguided but as long as
we keep her aimed in the right direction
she's great 100 are you ready for our
next story yes
you don't have anything to say it's just
the first story okay but it's more
reality TV news because Diddy and his
brood of seven will be getting the
reality TV treatment on Hulu hmm Sean
Diddy Combs seems to be following the
Kardashians to Hulu we hear the
entertainment Mogul is working with Hulu
on a reality series that will feature
him and his children tentatively titled
Diddy plus seven it's going to profile
the entire family they all have
businesses even the kids and it will
feature everyone a source familiar with
the project told page six Diddy and his
kids have already been spotted filming
the show in locations such as LA and
Miami according to sources
honestly up until you said Hulu I was
like this is weird because like reality
really is like low brow
um but something about Hulu obviously
like elevates it a lot and it makes it
better and then it's not a reality show
it's a documentary Series yeah but like
I don't know Diddy certainly doesn't
need the money but I do think um this is
a good family like I think Hulu needs
Diddy more than Diddy needs Hulu like
this is there's I feel like every family
thinks they have should have a reality
show and there's so many flops and a lot
of them don't and this I think given
that there's so many of them they have
enormous wealth so well connected I'm
sure they all have like good
personalities too I do think that this
is like a family ripe for reality I just
don't think that they need it even
though Hulu definitely is elevated yes I
don't think Diddy needs this but I think
it is like a really good thing to like
give to his children as a springboard
for whatever careers that they want to
have and it maybe they want to be an
entertainment and it's like this is a
really great way to set them up like
with actual jobs and if they have
companies like they said like it's a
great platform for their companies and
it's a it's a good like springboard for
your kids if you make the most of it no
totally then they all and he has seven
of them so it's not like he can ensure
seven kids could be a success like just
by his name alone alone
yeah and I do believe Diddy is a close
with the Kardashians I'm sure that like
he you know is learning from the best
I'm sure Kris Jenner is somehow involved
honestly yeah I think it'll come down to
like whether the kids have it you know
and their Dynamic is right right for TV
but I think there's a really good chance
that they do and they will be successful
in this just the nature of having seven
kids alone is interesting that's true
and of course the wealth is always
interesting to me yeah like
I think it's has every
ingredient for Success yeah but you like
they're just like I feel like a lot of
case studies we could point to of famous
families who have gotten reality shows
who you would think like they have money
they have it all but they genuinely
weren't interesting like the Bradshaw
Bunch never took off
yeah even living Lohan because they they
each had like a couple of the
ingredients
but not all of them and one of those
ingredients is a lot of kids
it's an ensemble it's true it's really
it's a group effort yeah it's a team
sport
are you ready for our next story was
actually more reality TV news no you're
not ready because I have to tell
everyone about a brand new sponsor that
we are so excited about because I feel
like you're thrived we've raved and
raved about Topgolf and now they are
joining our show as a sponsor it's golf
it's not golf it's Topgolf Jackie and I
actually recently had the best night out
on our Nashville trip we took a girls
trip to Nashville and we spent the
entire night at Topgolf it was a dream
it was so so fun the food was so good I
think we ate our weight in pizza but the
food was incredible so were the Vibes
and we had so much fun playing golf and
we were actually really good at it who
won
did you yep you think I would forget
even if you're into golf you'll love it
if you're not into golf it's so fun and
you can't help but get like competitive
and annoying and then like everybody
hates you that's what happened to me
um we're not huge golf girlies but it
was the perfect spot for a girls night
out and they just really have everything
they've got you know the clubs the balls
the t's the turf
um but they also have a bunch of stuff
that's not golf they've got great music
Big Targets on their Fairway huge TVs
handcrafted food Beverages and also
great spot for photos because we we went
to the one in Nashville it was gorgeous
and it wasn't particularly like warm up
but warm outside but all of their bays
are heated so you can go in the winter
you can go in the spring summer fall
um it was really like standing I got
like a gorgeous Instagram photo uh
that's on my Instagram if you want to
check it out yes so did we all also
it's great for girls to go alone but
it's also a great place to meet guys
it's a great place to meet guys we're
planning on going again on our Nashville
trip
um and we're all going as couples and we
were like what should we do on this
night and I suggested Topgolf because
it's literally perfect for a couples
trip it's perfect for a couple straight
out so they have everything that you
could possibly need they've got food and
beverage it's the only place you can
play around and then order another round
you can hit a slice and grab a slice
it's all the fun of outside but with the
Comforts of inside they have comfy
heated bays in the winter and cooled
bays in the summer so the Topgolf
experience is just a Vibe it's so much
fun it's great for a girl tonight it's
great for a couple tonight it's great
for you know you want to go meet guys
Jackie's totally right it's golf it's
not golf it's Topgolf download their app
book a bay and come play around you will
not regret it and you'll get a great
photo in the meantime
thank you Claudia
you're welcome
sort of a progression of news throughout
the week one Tyra Banks has left Dancing
with the Stars yes as a co-host and two
Julianne Huff is joining Alfonso Ribeiro
as the new Dancing with the Stars
co-host oh not as a judge as a host as a
host she went from dancer to judge to
now host ABC announced Monday that the
actress and professional dancer will be
returning to the Disney plus competition
series as a co-host alongside Alfonso
Ribeiro the announcement comes three
days after Friday's news that Tyra Banks
would exit the season the show after
three seasons
this was like such a weird thing that
happened at Dancing with the Stars like
they did not have a problem with their
hosts I feel like their hosts are
beloved Aaron and Tom they've been
around forever I think it was a lot of
people's favorite parts of the show so
there was a no problem to fix and they
came in with a wrench and a screwdriver
and tried to fix it so it was weird and
then they replaced them with Tyra Banks
and it just wasn't a job that Tyra Banks
was made like built for like I think she
really gave it her all but it's just not
what her skill set is best utilized to
do so it was a flop and there was and
honestly I don't know why Tyra Banks
would do it like the audience was just
like mean to her like every time she
like flubbed a word it would like go
viral so it wasn't a fun thing for Tyra
I don't think it wasn't the right fit
for Tyra and it never really needed to
be fixed in the beginning so it was like
they made this whole hoopla for what
yeah well now they've settled on two
people who are veterans of the show in
some way or another yes and I think that
they will actually be really good
Alfonso Ribeiro does a ton of Hosting
yep on his own and Julianne she does it
all she is just you know a five-trick
pony yeah no the two that they have now
I think are perfect one because Alfonso
is like a American Icon like and he's
known for like that dance and he has so
much hosting he hosts America's Funniest
Home Videos now which is like in yeah
the homes of millions of Americans like
he's really like America's sweetheart so
I think it's perfect of course Julianne
Huff is like a veteran of the show she's
a favorite of the show she's a very
skilled dancer she acts she hosts she's
perfect so they got to a good place like
I'm fairly confident in these two but I
don't know why they like went to go fix
something that wasn't broken well I
think they wanted to be more diverse
got it and then they also it was also
just like a transitive transitional time
for the show because they moved to Hulu
and they weren't on cable anymore so
they were like shaking things up all
around
um and I think the transition to Hulu
was actually successful I don't know if
it really affected their ratings
I feel like it did I haven't heard
anything about Dancing with the Stars
since they are no longer a weekly show
like on cable I mean yes because like I
only hear about it when you and Margo
are watching it and you just didn't
watch it but did you watch it because it
moved I no I didn't watch it because I
don't care like I really tried to get
into Dancing with the Stars but like at
its core like I just don't give a
like I I don't care really about dancing
and unless they had you know Taylor
Swift like there's no celebrity on there
that I'm really that passionate about
to tune in but I do think them having
Charlie demilio was like a huge get for
them and I think that really helped them
during the transition to Hulu you keep
saying Hulu by the way it's Disney plus
oh my God thank you for finally
correcting me I'm so sorry I thought
that like maybe there was a typo in the
article but they've said it a number of
times no no I forget like Hulu and
Disney plus are owned by the same parent
company and the demilio show is on Hulu
and we were just talking about Diddy so
I got my mice wires crossed thank you
yeah so that's exciting news and I look
forward to seeing what Tyra does next
because she is you know a rare talent
and I hope she does something awesome
because yeah but I think she almost they
really they set her up to fail like they
took two beloved hosts
and I get that they wanted to be more
diverse and I totally support that but
that's like a terrible position for Tyra
to be in because she's replacing two
people who really didn't need to be
replaced in terms of skill and in terms
of like cue score so she just went in as
like you know kind of the villain almost
and she was set up to fail yeah and it's
like this isn't even her area of
expertise like not that it is for Aaron
Andrews but they're like typical hosts
but Tyra while being a host is also like
a celebrity of Personality like model
you don't we don't get the tyrannous
that we love when she's really just
reading off of a teleprompter and asking
dancers how they feel yeah no it wasn't
it
should we be better as a judge yeah
Tyra's a star and the part of being a
host that a lot of people forget is that
it's not about you yes and it's it
wasn't the right role for her and I
think she would probably agree with that
you know whose job she should have taken
instead
who Chris Harrison
a hundred percent she would have been
amazing as a host who currently hosts
The Bachelor Jesse Palmer oh right right
I have not been keeping up with this
season and I just had a thought the
other day like I genuinely like
I can't believe there are people who
still watch The Bachelor like it's just
it's crazy to me well so I follow a lot
of Bachelor Nation you know from our
Heyday they're all just you know
influencers parents now so I just like
their content and a lot of them do still
watch because they I they do like little
Recaps here and there so that's really
how I get my information like I guess
like Zach who's the bachelor like he
wore flip-flops and and like broke up
with someone when it was like there were
a lot of bugs around okay well what I
know about this season that I actually
am really into is one of the a fan
favorite I don't know if she's still
there I don't know where we're at
currently but like she was top four at
least this week okay she got a HomeTown
and she's like a really really proud Jew
and she took him to cats they went to
Sarge's and he had like his pastrami
sandwich and get filter fish and she was
just like really showcasing her culture
and how proud she was her last name is
Frankel like I I did love that I I we've
never had that wait I'm obsessed her
name is Ariel or Arya
Arielle Franco she was eliminated and
weakness
well she made it pretty far she made it
to hometowns yeah and I think like she
was a fan favorite people loved her they
were shocked that she got sent home
maybe she'll be on Paradise well we need
to find her a Jewish King but if she it
like if she's if being Jewish is so
important to her but she was falling for
Zach I mean you know everyone's fallen
for everyone on that show like it's not
real it's not real now there's a Jewish
like if she went to Paradise heard the
Jewish guy Adam gotchalk was Jewish
obviously he's married with a baby now
but yeah I feel like there's like maybe
one maybe one that's funny I wouldn't
know because who was The Bachelor last
season at I don't know the guys but
right well I know I thought it was like
a nice thing that they you know
showcased she said that's cute yeah are
you ready for our next story which is
weirdly more reality TV are you okay no
because it's like technically Dancing
with the Stars is reality TV but it's
not like no it's like it's reality
competition right this is reality
competition American Idol judge Katy
Perry is in some hot water over a
comment that she made during someone's
audition she's okay by the way I watched
the Premiere she's like always saying
some out-of-pocket and I get it
it's hard to be like a star and your job
is really to in this role like hype up
other people but she like is always
making the auditions like about herself
and it's like kind of uncomfortable so
what did she do now okay so there was a
woman who came on who uh she looks very
young and she is she's 25 and before she
kicks off her audition she told Katie
and the other judges her age 25 and that
she has three children okay so all the
judges looked really surprised and Katy
Perry stood up as Luke Bryan began
Fanning her and the contestant said if
Katie lays on the table I think I'm
going to pass out
and Katy Perry said honey you've been
laying on the table too much
oh my God okay I want to say one thing I
want to say one thing did she mean
laying on like a hospital bed too so at
first I thought it was hospital bed and
I was like okay whatever but now it
sounds like you know get off your back
right you stop having kids right
oh no that's really that's a no bueno
that is no bueno so yeah no it's not
good especially Katie's a mom so I'm
sure that like she said it with no Mal
intent like whatsoever but it just you
know sometimes you have a joke in your
head and then what comes out it doesn't
land is not good
um fans I quickly went to social media
to express their disdain for the comment
and the contestant went to tick tock and
like did a video about how like it was
embarrassing to have that on TV and it
was hurtful I think that women
supporting an uplifting of their women
is so cool and I think that Mom shaming
is super lame and I think that it's hard
enough to be a mom and it's hard enough
to be a woman
um I definitely agree you know women
should support each other like when
applicable
women should support each other asterisk
but like Katie as a mom like it's just
like that's mean like it's mean but also
like I do think it's really important
that like we recognize like Katie's
intent versus her impact like I actually
don't know I don't think that Katie is
like a mom hater yeah you know she's
like a you only get one child sort of
person right
I just think it just came out a little
nasty we've all been there where we say
something that we think is going to be
funny and like it crosses the line like
I I gen they should have cut that out
for sure like why are they out here
making Katie look bad yeah um but Katie
in the in the um feels weird to call her
Katie sorry Katy Perry yeah she's like
always saying like some really
weird and me and better like when
we were watching we were like looking at
each other she's just like low-key
inappropriate
oh really you're like when there's like
really young hot guys she's like kind of
weird like she's just like kind of a
freak someone else used to do that on
American Idol and I was like this is
weird it's just bizarre yeah imagine if
the men did it right
right
so anyways
that was an odd moment and what's crazy
is they have like millions of hours of
footage and they like trip to put that
in no somebody at the network or like in
the editor's room hates Katy Perry
because that is something I would have
cut out if I'm like out here trying to
protect Katie's image yeah
totally now are you ready for our fifth
and final story I am which is not
reality TV news oh oh wow yeah Chris
Martin says he doesn't wait who's Chris
Martin Coldplay oh right okay sorry oh
my God you know when your brain link
doesn't work he says he doesn't eat
dinner after when this diet goes viral
one week after his ex-wife's
controversial diet went viral the
Coldplay front man told Conan O'Brien on
Conan's podcast that he does not have
dinner anymore he said I stopped eating
at four and I learned that from having
lunch with Bruce Springsteen I was lucky
enough to go over there to the lunch the
day after we played Philadelphia last
year he continued noting that he was on
a really strict diet anyway oop just
lost my article and he shared that he
was inspired to make spring seeds habits
his next challenge because the 73 year
old rocker looked more in shape than he
did at the time when Bruce's wife told
Chris that her husband only eats one
meal a day the singer thought well there
you go
Chris joked that his single meal
consists of a flank of buffalo with a
steroid sauce that's funny I just want
to say
um the way nobody's talking about this
compared to how they were talking about
Gwyneth like well this is it just
populated so give it a second because
this is selective outrage like let's see
no no it literally just I the episode I
just know I just know it's not gonna pop
off in the way that one it's the whole
thing did and this is why I don't take
any backlash seriously because people
don't actually care they just dislike
certain people and they make like big
kerfuffles about things that are never
really about the thing they're saying
it's about it's about the person and
Coldplay is like a beloved band and
Bruce is America's you know rockers the
boss you're so angry come for Bruce
right no if you really care come fast
and comfort for Chris Martin diet habits
except the only thing that they might
say is that Bruce didn't share that this
is what he does like he's not we're not
but Chris Martin did Chris Martin he's
learned it yeah no I'm sure they'll come
for Chris Martin I'm sure that that I
don't think that they will I don't think
that they will and I just I just think
this is literally the female Gwyneth
this is another teachable moment
selective outrage is a real thing yeah
but let's see how it plays out one meal
a day
I mean I guess you have a big lunch no
like I guess if like your plate like you
keep going up for re like for seconds
like throughout the day that's one meal
you know yeah yeah like if you have two
if you have dinner and you go for
seconds that's not two dinners because
it's like one seating you know no no but
I'm sure Chris Martin doesn't take
seconds if you okay here's a good
question if you could only have one meal
I don't know why you would be in this
situation but hypothetically if you had
to choose one meal to have every day
that you know you couldn't have the
others which meal would you want to have
I think I would have lunch at like three
o'clock
I mean like that makes sense time wise
like I just love dinner like dinner is
my favorite meal I don't ever look
forward to lunch I always hope for
health because like dinner's bad because
it's so close to bed I think for the
health people I'm not talking about
health I'm just saying like we're
picking favorites yeah no dinner is nice
but how are we gonna get through the day
I know and sometimes when like I have a
day I have a really early dinner five
o'clock dinner I'm always like literally
it's 4 59 I'm like ordering my dinner I
get like dinner I'm like Theo and Bruno
like I cannot eat dinner fast enough I
love dinner yeah those boys eat at five
o'clock and at 4 45 Bruno's looking at
me and I'm like it's in the fours Bruno
you can't have dinner yep by the way the
same exact experience at 4 45 Theo
stands by the door and he stands there
seriously looking at me for 15 minutes I
will not get up before 4 59 like once
the clock strikes five it's game on yeah
yeah and these boys know it too 100 they
could play us like a fiddle fiddle
they're Fiddlers those were good stories
you had said that the stories were like
trash I actually thought they were
pretty good
I just said this is these stories ugh
you did say that but sometimes like when
I say these stories are garbage I didn't
say that
you didn't say that I just said you like
stories are mad yeah yeah mad but but I
enjoyed them everything's met in
comparison to scandival
so true like we're chasing that high
constantly we are which is toxic you
know because those are people's lives
it's hard to remember that it's hard to
keep it in play into in check are we
toxic no I know I think we we try and
keep things in perspective like every
few minutes okay
well that's our show stay up with us on
social media to find out if we're gonna
be Audio Only tomorrow
um Jax I hope you feel better like take
the rest of the day you know give Zach
all your responsibilities and just like
I'll I'll take it from here thank you
turdy Lou thank you do you feel better
does the toast have healing restorative
properties I feel kind of the same but I
feel stable okay she's stable thank God
I feel stable okay love you guys dearly
thank you for
dealing with no video today I know you
miss these gorgeous faces thank you so
much for listening to the toast the
Monday Morning Show where we deliver the
fast five stories that you need to know
every Monday through Friday on YouTube
so if you're watching this on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
coming down so it's Spotify
talented we are hope you guys have an
amazing day and we'll see you um
tomorrow bye love you bye